- What, you don't think
I know what I'm doing?
- No, no, no, I'm not
saying that, I'm just...
- I'm saying both of you
don't know what you're doing.
(whimsical music)
- So I've actually never
seen a Dhar Mann video before
or Dhar Mhan or Dhar Man?
Apologies to Mr. Mann.
I've never seen one of your videos.
A couple of people asked
me to react to this
and based on the thumbnail,
this looks pretty terrible.
So let's react
to "Prosecutor Sends
Innocent Black Man to Jail".
- So you see, your honor,
it's without question
that this defendant did these crimes.
- No. That's impossible.
- Okay, who's the prosecutor
arguing in front of?
Where's the jury in this?
And why is the defendant
being allowed to speak at this point?
What part of the trial are we in?
This doesn't make any
sense right off the bat.
- I wasn't in Philly when it happened.
I was in LA at a Dodgers game!
- He's lying.
- I mean, you know,
you have a lawyer to talk
to the judge and the jury.
You're not really allowed to talk
unless you're on the witness
stand as the defendant.
This is already off the rails.
We're off to a cracking
good start here. (chuckles)
- You can tell by looking at him.
- Okay. Well, so that's
completely improper racism.
If there is a jury,
somewhere in this courtroom,
that's probably immediate
grounds for a mistrial.
You're not allowed to
engage in overt racism
while the trial is going on!
This is insane.
- Order!
(gavel bangs)
Defendant, do you have
any proof of your alibi?
- Oh, now I remember Dhar Mann.
I think Drew Gooden or Danny Gonzalez,
or both of them did a video on this.
They're videos where you...
It's totally unrealistic,
but you feel good at the end of the video.
Now, I remember.
- Uh, no, we don't have
any proof, your honor.
- Okay. Okay.
So (exhales) where are we
in the trial right now?
The judge is just flat asking the defense
if they have evidence.
There's a whole trial that you go through.
You call witnesses. You present evidence.
There are motions at limine
to admit things into evidence.
You don't just ask the council like,
"Do you have any evidence
to support your claim here?"
And why can't the defense
counsel come up with evidence
that this person wasn't even
in the city at the time?
- Okay, well, if there's no evidence
to corroborate Robert's story-
- That's insane!
(stammering) Okay, so
you're not in Philadelphia.
You're in Los Angeles.
How did you get there?
Who did you talk to?
Did you buy anything?
Did you make a cell phone conversation?
You brought your cell phone, right?
You have a mobile phone.
You could ping a cell tower.
You probably bought something.
You had to have a ticket
to get to Los Angeles.
He didn't walk there.
This is insanity! How...
There's no possible way
that a defense attorney
would be so incompetent as
to have zero evidence at all.
- Excuse me. I must use the restroom.
(Lionel running)
(clock ticking)
- And this is the thing
that really bothers me
is that even if you have a witness
and it's just, you know, he-said-she-said,
that's still considered evidence.
A witness testifying is
often direct evidence
and it's this, what a
lot of people consider,
the strongest you could have.
My mind is reeling.
It's absolutely a roller coaster
inside my brain right now.
Boy. Wow.
- The court finds the defendant
Robert Williams guilty.
- There's (stammering)
(Devin laughing)
There's no jury here. It's just the judge.
He's just... (laughing)
"Do you have any evidence
Mr. Defense council?
No? All right. Guilty."
That's not how a criminal trial works.
I mean, you know this.
There's a jury.
You walk to the jury, you present evidence
and then you instruct the jury.
(Devin laughing)
This is...
I'm already broken and we're
30 seconds into this video.
(Devin laughs)
- No.
No, please. Not my baby boy. (weeping)
- Okay, why are we letting
people in the gallery talk?
- I know he didn't!
- All right. Yeah, all right,
so there's an outburst.
- Please, you have to
believe me. I'm innocent!
I'd put that on my life!
You know I didn't do this.
You know it!
- Order!
Mr. Williams, that's enough
- I mean, does he?
- not another word.
- Why would the prosecutor
know he didn't do this?
The defense didn't present
any evidence whatsoever.
- We'll reconvene tomorrow for sentencing.
- Oh, yeah. Sentencing tomorrow. Yeah.
Courts are so backlogged, especially now.
Sentencing wouldn't happen
for probably a few weeks
I would think.
- Daddy!
No, please!
Don't go!
- Everything's gonna be
okay, sweetie, I promise.
Daddy loves you so much!
- What if he's telling the truth?
(Devin laughs)
What if we got the wrong guy?
- Yeah, we just convicted him.
What if he's telling the truth
based on absolutely nothing whatsoever?
- What, you don't think
I know what I'm doing?
- No, no, no, I'm not
saying that, I'm just...
- I'm saying both of you
don't know what you're doing.
- Wondering if maybe we
shouldn't take another look
at the facts.
- I just won a case. (laughs)
Who cares whether he did it or not?
- Okay.
Prosecutors are stereotyped this way,
but that's not the
philosophy that they have.
They want to convict people
that have actually done something.
And if someone didn't do
that, then by and large,
every prosecutor I know
would not want to convict that person.
Now, granted, I guess
there was a trial here
that we didn't see and
you got a conviction.
So there was evidence that
this person did something
and presumably it was evidence
beyond a reasonable doubt,
but, you know, still this is
not the time or the place.
- All that's important
is I'm one step closer to a promotion.
- Promotion for what? Is this guy...
Okay, so this guy must be an
assistant district attorney
or deputy district attorney.
I mean, what promotion is he angling for?
A management position of some kind?
Oh, and also,
so you convicted a guy of
assault with a deadly weapon.
This is as routine as it's going to get
for your sort of mid-level
felony district attorney.
Like that's not going to help
you get a promotion anywhere.
(chuckles) So dumb.
- And besides people like
him, they're all the same.
Just a bunch of criminals.
- All right. Great.
So we've got some overt racism.
Well, I mean, at least we
know who the bad guys are.
(paper rustling)
- Please.
Sir please. (weeping)
it's never too late to do the right thing.
- I mean, it is sort of too late.
He was convicted here.
It's really hard to undo a conviction.
There's not a whole lot
that you can do here,
but let's see.
(soft music)
- Yeah, well, I could
see my headlines now.
"DA Graham Gives Low-Life
Criminal Life in Prison".
- Yeah.
Well, okay, that headline
is not going to happen
because he was convicted of
assault with a deadly weapon,
which does not carry a
life sentence with it.
And I think you're already
the district attorney here.
Also, no newspaper is going
to run with that story
because this happens a
thousand times a day.
This is... (laughing)
Like, no one's going to care about this.
Oh man. So ridiculous.
- Keep up the great work.
- He's innocent!
- (chuckles) He's innocent.
- He's innocent.
- (sighs) Can you give us a minute?
- Yeah.
(Devin chuckles)
- What a deep(beep).
"He's innocent". What an ass(beep).
- What are you talking about?
- He wasn't in Philly when it happened.
His story checks out.
Look, I have his credit
card statements right here.
He was making purchases in Los Angeles
while the crime was happening.
- (laughs) What do you mean
you have his credit card statements?
Okay. Okay. All right.
If the district attorney had this evidence
and didn't turn it over to the defense,
that is a Brady Violation
left, right, and center.
That is ridiculous that they
wouldn't have turned that over
to the defense.
Presumably, they had to subpoena
the credit card company.
So they went through all the rigamarole
of getting this evidence.
If the prosecutor has
exculpatory evidence,
you have to turn that over to the defense.
So presumably, he had all of
this stuff in front of him.
He just didn't turn it
over to the defense.
So this is actually one of
those rare circumstances
where the defense would be probably able
to overturn this conviction.
So once the defense gets this evidence,
the defense would then file
a motion with the judge
to vacate the judgment
and to dismiss the
judgment with prejudice.
And then maybe you ask the
court to sanction the prosecutor
for very clear miscarriage of justice.
But, yeah, okay.
So that the prosecutors had this
from the very beginning is insanity.
- We have to get these to
the defense right away.
- Have you lost your mind?
- I mean, uh, maybe
somebody stole his card.
Maybe he gave it to him.
(Devin scoffs)
- Yeah. So it doesn't matter.
The prosecutor doesn't get to come up
with alternative explanations.
If the evidence is exculpatory,
you have to turn it over to the defense.
- I can think of a thousand reasons.
- Yeah, it doesn't
matter how many reasons.
- That's enough.
The case is over.
(paper tearing)
(somber music)
Do you hear me?
(coffee pouring)
- I have proof.
- What is it?
- You already had proof.
- I contacted a local convenience store
and I found a photo of him.
Take a look.
He couldn't have committed
a crime in Philly
if he was buying a hot dog in LA.
- Okay. So this is a little bit different.
This is newly acquired evidence.
So if the defense found this evidence
and they wanted to admit it
and overturn the initial conviction,
they would have had to have
filed a motion for new trial.
And the standard there is that
they wouldn't have been able
to discover this evidence
with reasonable diligence
before the trial itself.
But this probably wasn't
that hard to find.
They probably wouldn't have
been able to meet that standard
because this defense attorney
just completely dropped the ball
and said there was absolutely
no evidence at all.
However, since the prosecution now
has it in their possession,
it's probably still a Brady violation
that they're not turning it over.
But still, they didn't have the obligation
to affirmatively go out
and find this evidence
in the first place.
That's up to the defense.
And they dropped the ball.
- Doesn't even look like him.
- It's him. I had facial
recognition confirm it.
- What? What facial recognition?
This isn't an episode of "CSI".
(keyboard clacking)
- Has anyone else seen this?
- No, why?
- Good.
Let's keep it that way.
- Well, someone had to see it
because the district attorney
had to subpoena those records
from the convenience store.
(Devin laughing)
What papers is the defense
attorney reviewing right now?
Like the transcript where he says,
"No, we don't have any
evidence, your honor." (laughs)
It's kind of over and done.
Now we're just at the sentencing phase.
- You're not gonna believe this.
I have video evidence.
- What are you talking about?
- Well, a reporter was giving an interview
outside of the game.
(Devin chuckles)
- Okay, so?
- So guess who walks by?
There!
That's Robert.
- How would he have found that?
I mean, that's really
going above and beyond
to try and find this particular evidence.
Oh, and another thing!
This is the next day.
So we're assuming that
the district attorney
was somehow able to
subpoena a convenience store
and get it turned around
in like two hours.
This would have taken
this thing weeks or months
and same thing with finding
this video evidence as well.
I don't know how many times I've said
"That's ridiculous and unrealistic,"
but it's been a lot in this video.
- This, this proves...
- Okay. (laughs)
That fountain is nowhere
near Dodger Stadium.
I guess that's the Los Angeleno in me,
but I mean, that's also ridiculous.
- His innocence.
We have to tell the judge.
- Yes. You do have to tell the judge.
- Have a seat.
- We have to tell the judge!
- We don't have to tell a soul!
- Yes, you do.
- It's, you know, in the constitution.
- Mr. Graham, anything you want to share?
- No, your honor.
- Very well. Mr. Williams.
- Okay.
Another thing, maybe this is small
in the grand scheme of things,
but I would sue the crap out
of the defense attorney here,
because I mean, this is
Ineffective Advice of Counsel.
This is really terrible representation.
Not only is he not finding the evidence
that's laying in front of him,
but he's completely
botched this entire case.
So yeah, this guy has
a great cause of action
against his former attorney
because this guy is the worst.
- Federal statute requires
a 25-year mandatory minimum sentence.
- Federal statute?
This is state court in Philadelphia.
This has nothing to do
with federal courts at all!
And 25 years!
This is assault with a deadly weapon.
Okay, first of all, in Pennsylvania,
that's a maximum of 10 years in prison,
and the reality is he's
gonna get like 70 months.
So he's probably convicted for incentives
for less than six years.
Presuming since this guy
is completely innocent,
this is probably his first offense,
so yeah, he's at the
low end of the spectrum,
maybe five to six years in jail.
Not 25 years in jail for
assault with a deadly weapon.
Ridiculous!
- You've already been found guilty.
So unless the people have anything else...
- If only there had been a trial
in front of some sort
of jury of your peers
where you could present evidence,
but sadly, that's not the
world we live in. (laughs)
- This court hereby sentences
the defendant Robert Williams,
to 25 years in a federal prison
without the possibility of parole.
- (chuckles) Okay.
A Pennsylvania court has no authority
to send you to federal prison.
That's not a thing.
(Robert's family sobbing)
(somber music)
(Devin laughing)
- Okay.
The judge has already made his sentence.
Like banging the gavel
to the extent the judge ever does that,
which is not often,
it doesn't carry any specific weight.
It's not like, "Nothing I said matters
until I smack this wooden
hammer against the table!"
It's over. It's over at this point.
(dramatic music)
(Devin speaking distortedly)
- Wait!
(Devin laughs)
- Excuse me?
- Wait, I'm sorry, your
honor. He didn't do it.
May I approach the bench?
- You may.
(people whispering)
- Your honor, there is no way
that Mr. Williams committed those crimes.
- You don't have to interrupt the court
and present all your evidence.
That's actually probably sort of improper.
You'd probably ask to adjourn
this particular sentencing
so that you can talk with the defense
so that everyone can
present their motions.
But, you know, Dhar Mann
gonna Dhar Mann I guess.
- You see, I have here
a credit card statement
showing purchases made by the
defendant with his credit card
in Los Angeles on the same day
that the crime took place in Philadelphia.
- Is there...
- And I also have-
- There's got to be a
chain of custody issue.
- A photo of the defendant
in the convenience store
here in Los Angeles buying a hot dog,
just mere moments before
the crime took place.
And I have a video as well, your honor.
So you see, your honor,
Robert Williams could not
have committed those crimes.
- (sighs) Is, uh...
Is all this true, Mr. Graham?
- Well, uh-
- Why didn't you say anything?
(Graham sighs)
- Because he was more
interested in his promotion
than he was and saving in
innocent man from jail.
- Again, I can't fathom what promotion
he's angling for here.
And also, like, okay, you
presented your evidence.
You don't necessarily need to
throw this guy under the bus.
And frankly, I think,
some of these discussions
are probably privileged.
(Devin laughs)
You know, whatever.
I mean at this point. Sure, why not?
- Well, what'd you expect? Huh?
Okay, so maybe he didn't do this crime!
But I'm sure he's done dozens of others!
- You're god(beep) right I
ordered the code red! (laughs)
That does not happen.
- Look at him! He's clearly a criminal!
- Your honor!
- Order!
- Yeah! Finally!
Finally, the defense objects
to, like, overt racism.
Oh, boy.
Where have you been, buddy?
- I've heard all I needed
to hear. Mr. Williams?
The charges against you have been dropped.
You're free to go.
Bailiff, uncuff him immediately.
- Oh, okay. Yeah. I mean, sure.
Why not?
- And you,
- Sua sponte motion to vacate.
Ah, okay, I'll allow it.
- Mr. Graham.
- Oh, please.
- Obstructing justice and
tampering with evidence
is a very serious crime.
- Your honor-
- I'm going to see to it
that not only do you
never practice law again,
but that we send the right
man to jail this time.
You.
Bailiff, arrest him.
- Okay. (laughs)
This guy may have been...
God! Is that has that
obstruction of justice? Maybe.
That might give rise.
I mean, mainly it's just a
really horrible Brady violation
and I don't know that that
necessarily gives rise
to obstruction of justice.
Either way, I don't think
the judge has the power
to have the bailiff arrest this guy.
You would probably refer
him to Bar Council for sure
and maybe you refer to another prosecutor
based on the facts.
But, yeah, I don't think there's any world
in which this guy is arrested
after a sentencing hearing like this.
You know, you've got to
engage in discovery too.
Okay. I'm done.
No more. No more.
- No!
No, this can't be happening!
- Yeah, it literally can't be happening.
- Let me go!
(Robert family's crying)
- Sir.
Why did you help us?
- Well, because a wise woman once told me,
"It's never too late
to do the right thing."
- Isn't that a "30 Rock" joke.
Oh, no, wait. It's close,
but almost as cringey.
But it's cringey on purpose.
(laughs) God!
♪ It's never too late for now. ♪
(Robert's family weeping)
(soft music)
- (laughs) That's not a newspaper.
It's like one of those fake things
that you print out in like Print Shop.
I mean, at least make it big!
It's 8 1/2 by 11. "The Daily News".
(soft music)
(Devin laughing)
♪ It's never too late for now. ♪
- Hey, Dhar Mann fam!
So you see, we're not
just telling stories,
we're changing lives!
- Okay, he knows that this
didn't actually happen.
No one's life was changed here.
This is a fictional story that
didn't happen in real life.
No one... (laughs)
Look, I'm on YouTube, too.
We're not necessarily changing lives here.
We're making things that are entertaining.
Slow your roll, buddy.
- And when you share my videos,
you're helping to change lives, too!
- I mean, come on now.
Now, when you share a Legal Eagle video,
of course, you're changing lives.
But the Dhar Mann video,
I'm not sure about that.
Okay, let's put me out of my misery.
Let's give this thing a
grade for legal realism.
(whimsical music)
On the plus side,
I guess they use terms like "defendant"
and "district attorney".
Other than that, kind of nothing.
On the other side, pretty much everything.
This is the most unrealistic
thing I've ever seen.
It's procedurally and
substantively improper.
Yeah, this is the worst fictional account
of a legal proceeding
I've ever seen in my life.
F!
Now, you might be dumber for
having watched this video,
but you won't be with
today's sponsor Morning Brew.
I've actually been subscribed
to Morning Brew for forever.
It's one of my absolute
favorite newsletters
and it's awesome that they
wanted to sponsor this channel.
Morning Brew, if you didn't know,
is a free daily newsletter
delivered Monday through Sunday.
It gets you up to speed
on business, finance, tech,
and law in just five minutes.
And it provides a fantastic quick survey
of the most important issues
while being witty,
irreverent, and informative.
And did I mention it's completely free?
And it tells me how much
my stocks are going up
and how much everyone
else's crypto is going down.
This week, for example,
I learned about Elon Musk
leaving California for Texas,
Twitch getting hacked, the
Facebook whistleblower,
and a vegan shrimp
substitute called vrimp.
Hmm.
It's basically exactly the mix of news
that I'm actually interested in
and the stuff I didn't know
I wanted to know about,
and it's all written in a hilarious style.
Morning Brew is one of the few emails
that I actually open religiously.
So Legal Eagles, this one
is a complete no brainer.
Morning Brew is completely free
and it takes less than
15 seconds to subscribe.
Just click on the link
that's on screen now
or in the description to
get Morning Brew for free.
And not only will you get a newsletter
that you'll actually read,
but you'll actually be
helping out this channel, too.
So click on the link below to
get Morning Brew right away.
And while you're at it,
check out this playlist
with all of my real lawyer reactions.
So click on this playlist
or I'll see you in court.